[Musique]
merci de nous rejoindre sur tv 78e pour
un point sur l'actualité yvelinoise
nouvelle édition spéciale en ce mardi 21
avril 36e jours de confinement et pour
débuter un chiffre 11 mille c'est le
nombre d'habitants à villepreux mais
aussi le nombre de masque en tissu que
la ville souhaite confectionner d'ici au
11 mai date annoncée du début de
déconfinement en france elle en appelle
donc à l'élan de solidarité qui s'est
déjà manifesté ces dernières semaines si
vous résidez dans la commune que vous
souhaitez confectionner ces masques vous
pouvez récupérer sur rendez-vous du
matériel en mairie un kit comprenant du
tissu homologué des élastiques et des
patrons depuis le 16 avril plus de 100
personnes se sont inscrites plus de
quatre mille masques devrait pouvoir
être distribués ensuite avec plus de
vingt mille décès en france depuis le
début de l'épidémie l'activité des
pompes funèbres doit-elle aussi se
réorganiser la plus importante elle ne
doit pas se faire aux dépens de la santé
des salariés
les professionnels doivent aussi
expliquer aux familles certaines
nouvelles contraintes
écoutez ce témoignage recueilli par
mathilde et demi en temps normal on est
appelés pour un décès donc on a une
prise en charge de tf1 qui se fait comme
on dit à visage découvert la prise en
charge est tout à fait classique sans
précaution particulière pour les
qu'ovide c'est une autre façon de
travailler
on a reçu effectivement un dernier
décret qui nous a dit ben non les mises
en bière seront faites immédiatement sur
le lieu du décès et sans présentation
famille donc si le foot et la prise en
charge d'un corps ça nous donne quand
même plus de travail parce que on est
obligé déjà de préparer le cercueil on
est obligé de partir le plus rapidement
possible puisque le délai donné par la
préfecture était mise en bière dans les
24 heures certaines maisons de retraite
evad ont mis ça à leur propre sauce en
fait ils m'ont dit nous on préfère que
les corps parce que rapidement dans
certaines maisons de retraite ou nous
demander de faire la mise en bière dans
les 10 heures nous allons parler à
présent d'une rencontre de jeunes
entrepreneurs des yvelines et c'est le
confinement qu'il l'a rendu possible
nous
sommes avec camille lefeuvre présidente
et fondatrice de ph fragrance bonjour
vous êtes au mesnil-le-roi et nous
sommes aussi avec julie et kevin antoine
du studio jules bonjour à vous de à vous
deux pardon vous êtes à maisons laffitte
on va parler de votre rencontre
virtuelle de votre collaboration va tout
d'abord présenté aussi pour les
téléspectateurs vos activités
respectives
camille lefeuvre votre entreprise
propose des parfums de luxe des produits
parfumés réalisé avec un cahier des
charges très restrictif
c'est une marque qui se veut sans aucun
produit toxique c'est bien ça déjà pour
vous présenter
nous on a mal on a créé la chimie qui
une écologie et on a parfois paru marron
donc on a des parfums et suivent des
bougies les batwa parfum des gels
douches ddo est décrié derrière moi on a
obtenu pas mal de prix sur notre
engagement pour la santé ou
l'environnement
on va effectivement interdit qu'une 120
gagnant contre lui c'est en plus des
réglementations en vigueur avant de
confinement comment se porte votre
activité justement plutôt bien ça a été
plus compliqué avec le début du go
finement et cette crise
oui c'est évident nous on est au tout
début plein prix pour notre formation on
évite en france ensuite aussi en
angleterre sur le confinement à cette
crise énorme sur nos petites start-up il
ya les magasins sont fermés
comment penser c'est effectivement la
réalité déjà entre julie et quémandent
antoine votre studio est donc basé photo
studio de photographie à
maisons-laffitte ou vous adresser aux
familles aux professionnels aussi
aujourd'hui votre activité est
totalement à l'arrêt ouais clairement
clairement pas forcément avec le
confinement plus personne ne peut sortir
donc tout ce qui est chouette un petit
peu particulier basse est à l'arrêt
les grosses marques avec lesquelles on
bosse notamment bosse avec l agence de
mannequins élite on bosse avec beaucoup
de marques de prêt-à-porter évidemment
pas toutes se quitter les campagnes
photos sont pour le moment reporter en
espérant que ce ne soit pas annulée donc
c'est vrai que bon là du temps on a du
temps ça c'est pour ça qu'avec a mis bas
on lui a suggéré qu'on s'est posé la
question aux exigences éthiques qu'est
ce qu'on pourrait faire pour aider les
gens se rendent ce temps de crise on a
réfléchi on s'est dit ce que l'on sait
coudre
non on est bête saab annonce donc on
s'est dit voilà jutier mal qu'un mois je
suis photographe et on s'est dit tiens
si on pouvait aider les créateurs à
faire face à un petit peu alors on
pesant un petit peu de contenu en leur
faisant des photos avec avec lui avec
pied avec moi et on a même mis les
enfants à contribution les massacres et
peut-être un petit peu je sais pas moi
donner un petit coup de main ces
entrepreneurs sont dans les difficultés
d'où c'est comme ça qu'est venu en fait
finalement ben notre envie de voir bhp
de travail et camier oui on avait
proposé gratuitement vos services pour
créer en quelques jours et pendant le
confinement c'est une publicité
on va voir la fiche est d'ailleurs à
l'antenne pendant qu'on parlait com
comment s'est passé le travail un petit
peu pour arriver à cette création de
part et d'autre comment vous avez
échangé et ben en fait on a en en amont
à communiquer avec camille on voit là on
lui a dit voilà écoute on lui a soumis
ce projet on lui a expliqué un petit peu
ce doute à ce qu'on pouvait le faire ce
dont elle avait besoin
donc elle nous a fait parvenir de
l'envoyer des produits nous envoyer un
parfum envoyée voilà une petite lessive
à nous envoyer plusieurs petits produits
laon celui bâtir le parfum c'est super
julie bas qu'à l'habitude de travailler
beaucoup en cosmétique qui fait la une
en rêvant pub que ce soit télé ou alors
des affiches mois voilà pour par contre
beaucoup de cet immense et tient le
parfum ce serait vraiment quelque chose
vous pourrez tous éclaté en tant que
photographe qui pourrait servir à
camille pour ça comme donc on a mis un
chute en place assez rapidement
voilà à la maison et on peut donc là
c'est parti comme ça et on a mis aussi
d'ailleurs
après le chute à contribution nos
internautes
notre réseau donc retoucheur graphistes
etc pour pouvoir monter une affiche vrai
rond et tout ça gratuitement évidemment
28 ans était gratuitement et lyne
lefebvre justement c'est cette
initiative
ça permet de soutenir aussi votre
activité ça permet une solidarité entre
entrepreneurs
tout à fait ces initiatives forcément
chaud au coeur c'est une très belle
initiative une très belle en paix dans
toit en toit entrepreneurs donc ces
initiatives des mois j'ai été très
touchée il ya eu plus de 1500 personnes
qui ont participé de nos réseaux à sur
la fiche et l'affichent avoir magnifique
et du coup moi j'ai relayé également sur
des réseaux sociaux linkedin instar
facebook il ya eu trente mille pub en
que quelques heures de m'initier hâtive
a été fait une cité les rendre aussi un
qui peut nous convenir
et donc j'ai décidé c'est que tout achat
de produits instant mails sur le site
internet est à 50 euros qui sont
reversés au fonds ap-hp qui ne font
l'objet les esprits les hôpitaux de
paris paris est fait pour les médecins
et pour la recherche
c'est ma petite contribution
un homme c'est dans ces moments un
traître une solidarité de part et
d'autre qui s'est organisée joli et
kevin antoine vous continuez ce genre
d'initiative avec d'autres entreprises
d'autres shooting photo je dis qu'on n'a
pas encore entendu il sera mis à
contribution aussi je veux on a plein
plein de marques de prêt-à-porter une
bonne dizaine facile de deux jeunes
entreprises créateurs et ça va permettre
des collaborations futures peut-être on
imagine aussi ça permet d'étoffer le
carnet d'adressés parce que ces
entreprises
l'un comme l'autre va bien falloir les
faire vivre aussi après au moment du
décompte final
c'est vrai quand c'est non c'est pas
forcément le but on sait pas où on va on
va shooter les marques ont après
bosser bosser avec lui en fait on a on a
lancé le vraiment les shootings gratuit
pour aider les entrepreneurs
après on verra évidemment c'est sûr si
on travaille bien et que bas les
entreprises ont besoin pour le futur de
photo fnac ils font appel à nous mais
c'est vrai que s'ils font pas la peine
qu'on sait pas c'est pas le but on est
vraiment là dans une dans une optique
d'entre aide parce que ben voilà c'est
un peu la situation actuelle qui
nécessite de qu'on soit tous les uns
avec les autres pour pouvoir tous basm
elle met à contribution mais pourquoi
faire face à cette crise
merci à tous les trois jours donne le
nom de rose entreprises elles
s'affichent aussi les sites internet le
studio jules que donc et créach
fragrance
merci à tous les trois et bravo pour ces
initiatives merci à vous 6
parmi les commerces fermés et qui
souffrent de cette crise les librairies
depuis peu il est possible pour elle de
reprendre une activité partielle via la
vente en ligne avec retrait devant leurs
portes en respectant bien évidemment les
règles sanitaires en vigueur
aurélie rose patrick jacques de dixmude
sont allés rencontrer le gérant du pavé
du canal un bon de signer le bretonneux
continuer l'activité de la librairie
pour vendre son stock
voici ce qui a poussé laurent garin
directeur du pavé du canal à montigny le
bretonneux de rouvrir les portes de son
établissement une ouverture partielle
puisqu'il propose à ses clients un point
relais un service qui était encore
impossible il ya quelques jours il ya eu
un appui du pardon de la part du
syndicat de la librairie française pour
que ça passe enfin comme un produit de
première nécessité donc on n'y a plus de
ya plus de restrictions en soit sur le
déplacement avec justificatifs pour
venir acheter les niveaux je suis venu
le récupérer des suites de bande
dessinée pour les enfants qui lisent
beaucoup en ce moment à la maison faits
qui sont dedans pour les commandes tout
se passe en ligne
l'électeur vérifie que les livres soient
bien disponible et envoient leur demande
par mail
le paiement se fait uniquement par
chèque a décidé de pas avoir plus de 2 3
personnes par créneau par quart d'heure
donc ils prennent date sur un rendez
vous ici et ils nous envoient un mail
avec une liste et nous on leur envoie le
montant de la commande en leur précisant
que le créneau a été validée qui a déjà
dit
hydro alcoolique il ya forcément on sait
un mètre de distance entre la clientèle
et moi mais voilà donc les gens viennent
sur ces créneaux et voilà comment on
fonctionne
j'ai pas mal de bouquins parce que
j'avais j'ai toujours un stock sous la
main et j'en avais pris aussi à la
médiathèque
mais c'était surtout la possibilité de
soutenir la livre et je sais que c'est
important de soutenir les commerces
locaux et le centre vide qui est
important de ce meeting plus de quarante
mille ouvrages sont en stock
parmi les plus plébiscités les livres
jeunesse et les livres de cuisine et si
certains secteurs tentent de s'organiser
malgré tout pour faire face d'autres en
revanche n'ont pas ce choix ainsi la
ville de trappes vient de faire le point
sur sa programmation événementielle
si l'on savait que le semi marathon ou
encore le forum de l'emploi était
annulée on apprend que l'opération ville
en fête du samedi est 21 juin sera
reportée en septembre
et puis côté saison culturelle le
spectacle du pokemon crew est reportée
au 23 janvier 2021 le concert de cover
queen au 9 janvier 2021 et celui de skip
the use au 16 octobre de cette année les
billets restent valables mais vous
pouvez obtenir un remboursement en
envoyant un mail directement auprès de
la salle de la merise
[Musique]
oui
nous restons dans le domaine de la
musique et des arts avec le travail mené
par le conservatoire gabriel fauré de
rambouillet si l'établissement est fermé
depuis le 16 mars les initiatives se
multiplient de la part de son directeur
de ses professeurs et de ses adhérents
des vidéos régulièrement sont postés sur
les réseaux des danseurs des chanteurs
se met en scène l'enseignement aussi se
poursuit avec des échanges par
visioconférence et une chorale virtuelle
devrait également voir le jour le 20
avril indice devait se tenir le meeting
marathon de boston confinement oblige
l'événement a été reportée en septembre
pour autant cela n'a pas découragé sidy
diallo dont nous vous avons déjà parlé
sur cette antenne ce résidant de
montigny le bretonneux ancien diplomate
a déjà réalisé 225 course de ce type
la plupart pieds nus et cette fois ci
c'est au coeur de sa maison qu'il a
renouvelé l'exploit mathilde de 2010 et
patrick jacques de dixmude pour ce
reportage
il ne pourra pas participer comme prévu
au marathon de boston reporté en
septembre pour cause d'épidémie du coc
vite 19 limité à une heure par jour
pendant le confinement pour aller courir
sidy diallo a décidé de reproduire chez
lui les 42 kilomètres de cette course
emblématique pieds nus l'idée de courir
aujourd'hui devant nous sommes encore
film en moi j'essaie de motivation pour
courir partout
le confinement ne l'affectent pas je
respecte les règles et je sais pas tu
m'as vu je coule si la chaussée il n'y a
pas de voiture et à personne et je suis
très très loin des gens quand je cours
si la chaussée mais je sais déserte et
je suis loin de maison et quand je
rencontre des personnes qui sont sur le
trottoir je vais l'autre côté des sa
cuisine jusqu'à dans sa chambre ce
marathonien cours dont chaque recoin de
son appartement sur un carnet notre
chaque aller-retour pour comptabiliser
le nombre de kilomètres effectués 100
200 300 400
comment faire pour que j'arrive à 844 à
chaque fois que j'avais plus de cinq
kilomètres je note l'heure à laquelle je
suis arrivé comme daddy cool ça chez lui
sidy diallo s'est préparé un parcours de
25 m en ajoutant les quinze marge de son
escalier pour ce marathonien de 65 ans
impossible pour lui d'arrêter de courir
malgré le confinement
ça fait 12660 marche que je dois monter
et descendre aujourd'hui donc là je suis
à 25 km donc j'ai encore du chemin et
mais c'est un problème
alors voilà les escaliers et agira tout
le monde a des escaliers soit pour la
cave soit plus à l'est aussi
au grenier ou là les immeubles aussi l
cage d'escalier et ici je crois tout le
monde prend l'ascenseur donc en fait la
cage d'escalier aussi est libre on peut
faire de l'exercice tout en respectant
les règles de ce barrière le confinement
de puits notre tournage sidy diallo a
fini son marathon à domicile en
challenge qu'il a relevé pour
transmettre un message positif et
énergique pendant cette période de
pandémie
confiné il est donc possible de relever
des exploits sportifs il est aussi est
possible pour ceux qui n'auraient pas le
courage de se promener au milieu du zoo
parc de thoiry
tous les mardis tous les jeudis à 14
heures et ce jusqu'au 11 mai le parc
propose est des live sur sa page
instagram pour partir à la rencontre des
animaux elle lémuriens panthères de
chine ta pierre terrestre et bientôt les
girafes et panda roux n'auront plus
aucun secret pour vous d'autant qu'il
est même possible de poser ses questions
en live au soigneur extraits
les makis cattas vont communiquer entre
eux par petits cris assez stridente
notamment un petit cri qui ressemble à
un miaulement d'où leur nom maki catta
mais aussi beaucoup par les odeurs
donc ils ont niveau des poignets c'est
parce qu'ils mathieu peut réussir à
filmer peut-être l'intérieur du poignet
d'un maquis catr on voit une petite
excroissance noir et celle ci va donner
faire excrété des odeurs notamment des
phéromones qui va leur permettre de
communiquer donc c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs quatre fois rit on vous
demande toujours de ne pas toucher les
lémuriens sais pas pour vous embêter
c'est pour qu'ils puissent conserver
leur identité puisque leur odeur c'est
vraiment ce qui va caractériser leur
identité et si vous les touchez vous
mettez votre odeur sur eux et du coup
ils risquent pas de se faire rejeter par
les autres et ça peut créer des conflits
fin de cette édition spéciale je vous
retrouve demain à 19 heures pour faire
le point sur l'actualité des yvelines
nos reportages sont à retrouver sur les
réseaux sociaux sur notre site internet
également
n'hésitez pas à prendre contact avec
nous à l'adresse qui s'affiche sur votre
écran prenez soin de vos proches et de
vous à demain
[Musique]